moniteur de savate et maintenant
écrivain alexandre foucher du club de
boxe française savate d'elancourt
maurepas vient de publier un livre
baptisé mémoire de savate un récit
descriptif sur lequel il a travaillé
pendant neuf mois sportifs y raconte son
amour pour ce sport et son expérience au
sein du club yvelinois j'ai eu comme un
besoin d'écrire ce livre de raconter un
petit peu une expérience que j'ai vécue
que j'ai apprise en prenant en charge ce
club et en essayant avec nos moyens de
justement créer une activité de le
mettre beaucoup plus présents au sein
des ville d'elancourt et de maurepas et
grands fait tout ce témoignage la
finissait par créer une certaine
richesse et je quelque part peut-être
que j'avais peur qu'on m'oublie les 150
pages de ce livre ont également pour
vocation de changer les mentalités sur
la savate une discipline qui compte plus
de cinquante mille licenciés en france
l'objectif c'est aussi montrer l'état
d'esprit de la savatte qui est plus que
on a souvent une idée de la boxe de
quelque chose de cogneurs de quelque
chose de gens diraient qu'ils
réfléchissent pas et qui est et qui font
sens dans le tard je pense que c'est une
mauvaise opinion qu'on a sur l'ensemble
des sports de combat et particulièrement
sur la savate qui se veut éducative et
esthétique qui se veut aussi éthique et
tous ces valeurs là j'ai voulu les faire
rentrer dans le club le livre
d'alexandre touchette a retrouvé sur les
plateformes de vente en ligne peut être
également commandé dans les libres et
des yvelines le tarif est de 12 euros